[Music]
this week the department of justice at
the behest of joe biden decided that
parents who stand up for their kids at
school board meetings should be
investigated as domestic terrorists
their message is loud and clear to moms
and dads across america if you disagree
with the radical left you're going to be
targeted and silenced but many parents
are fighting back joining me now is asr
namani with parents defending education
thanks for taking the time to join me
tonight i can see that sign that's
behind you what are you taking that to
well here i see here i sit i'm right
outside luther jackson middle school
fairfax county public school board is
going to have their meeting tonight and
right now there's a hundred parents
outside with signs like this and they
are standing defiant of this threat by
the justice department and the fbi to
shut them down parents are going to
stand up defending children and
defending education do you think that
you're going to be getting some
attention from the fbi perhaps after
taking such a stand
you know what
parents are saying things like bring it
on arrest me because
there's nobody who can stand between a
mama bear and papa bear and their cub i
mean it's unconscionable what the
justice department is doing and what
they are really doing is protecting
political and business interests that
lead right to the justice department in
the
education industry that is exploiting
our children and so we have to return
back to the abc's as one mom just told
me and stop with all of this
indoctrination ah sir i know that this
is something that you woke up to perhaps
earlier than many in this country in
terms of the developments that played
out over the past year plus tell me a
little bit about your reaction though to
this
what i think a lot of people think feel
like they never could have seen happen
in this country parents being tagged as
domestic terrorists potentially for
wanting to seek out the best for their
children's education children's
education yeah it's this is just
unbelievable to me my father came to
america in the 1960s as an immigrant
from india bringing me we lived in
poverty our first years i was in english
a second language student i learned
english with nancy drew and thus i come
into this country and i believe that
education is our stepping stone right my
son went to one of the best high schools
here in fairfax county virginia
but they told our mostly immigrant
mostly minority parents that we had to
start checking our privileges just
because our kids were at this school and
that's when i woke up and realized they
were putting a target on the backs of
parents and now we have that confirmed
with this ridiculous justice department
declaration of war on us people have to
be very clear that stand clear for your
values and be unapologetic as a parent
i remember back you know 20 years ago
there were a lot of concerns being
raised in the wake of the patriot act
about it being misused against domestic
people particularly against muslims in
america this seems like the kind of
thing that should arouse the offense of
every american regardless of whether
you're on the right or the left today
every single american should be outraged
right now at this overreach by
the justice department i am muslim i
have chased terrorists around the world
i have gone to go on guantanamo bay to
stare khaled sheikh muhammad in the eyes
and i can tell you that these parents
they have names like harry and stacy and
suparna they're good
good people just like parents all over
this country and the justice department
has waged a war on the wrong people we
are the protectors of children and they
must stand with us not against us this
is so so disheartening but
we will not be disheartened because we
have clarity in our eyes and those are
the faces of our children osra thanks so
much for joining me and good luck at
your school board meeting
oh my gosh thank you i hope everyone
gets their popcorn and watches the live
stream
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else